big things come in small packages
especially when you've got a super
mushroom handy but how did these
Brooklyn Brothers become the heroes of
toads and New Yorkers alike here's the
ending of the Super Mario Brothers movie
explained
Mario and Luigi receive more character
development in the Super Mario Brothers
movie than they've had in any previous
Incarnation even going so far as
introducing their loud large
Italian-American Family Video Game
Publications like the gamer praised
Chris Pratt and Charlie Day who voiced
the pair with vocal chemistry that feels
like fireworks over a castle
do you think I know every human being
with them that's wearing a magnet
air of his first name on it because I
don't that being said Mario and Luigi
spent the bulk of the Super Mario
Brothers movie apart Luigi is captured
by Bowser's evil forces early on placing
him in the traditional Damsel in
Distress role their conflict-free
supportive relationship in the film's
opening drives Mario's desire to rescue
Luigi throughout the film but he still
finds himself struggling to master the
weird rules of the Mushroom Kingdom
during The film's climactic Showdown
with Bowser a beaten up Mario finds
himself in the pizzeria from the film's
opening watching the plumbing company
commercial he and Luigi spent all their
money to make he's reminded of how his
brother makes him feel like a superhero
which goes back to his defense of Luigi
as kids it makes for a thrilling end to
the film as the two brothers work
together to take on Bowser
in one of the film's first scenes Mario
and Luigi's Pizzeria celebration is cut
short by form and Spike their former
boss who mocks their plumbing company
and physically intimidates an
overconfident Mario when he tries to
defend his brother as Luigi remarks
during this scene Mario is crazy to
stand up to someone three times his size
his introduction to Princess Peach
emphasizes this as she remarks about how
small Mario is Mario's lack of strength
is a sore spot for the Brooklyn plumber
although he's given a chance to prove
himself when King Cranky Kong demands
that he fight his son Donkey Kong if he
wins cranky will lend his army in
defense of the Mushroom Kingdom
ultimately it's Mario's heroism and
found confidence that not only wins over
Donkey Kong in the end but even form and
Spike who leads a crowd in Brooklyn
cheering on the Mario Brothers
Luigi is Mario's cowardly brother whose
anxiety and fear are established early
in the movie an early moment that
cements his personality occurs at a
plumbing job gone wrong where Luigi is
attacked by a dog after he steps on its
bone however this fear pales in
comparison to Luigi's Terror when he
ends up sucked into the dark lands and
separated from Mario in a scene that
will Delight fans of Luigi's Mansion
Luigi abandons his flashlight to outrun
a horde of dry bones ending up in a
castle where he's ambushed by shy guys
in a later flashback Luigi reminisces on
his childhood years when Mario rescued a
Meek Baby Luigi from a playground bully
by the time Luigi reunites with Mario
during the film's third act Luigi has
found his courage while trying to save
his brother for once as Mario is about
to be engulfed by Bowser's Flames Luigi
defends him with a manhole cover then
the two take the Superstar for
themselves and use it to defeat Bowser
nevertheless Luigi may find new reasons
to be scared in the future especially if
day lives up to his hope of wanting to
do a Luigi's Mansion move movie
little is known about Peach from the
Super Mario Brothers game series despite
being playable in titles like Super
Mario Brothers 2 super Princess Peach
and Super Mario 3D World for fans of
Mario's frequent Damsel in Distress the
character gets a great opportunity to be
fleshed out with her role in the Super
Mario Brothers movie in contrast to her
more helpless video game appearances
Anya Taylor Joy's Princess Peach is a
full-blown fighter but she wasn't always
that way
there's a huge Universe out there during
a scene in a fire flower field Peach
opens up to Mario about her past she
reveals that as a baby she stumbled out
of a green pipe into the Mushroom
Kingdom where she was taken in by the
Toads the cute citizens of the Mushroom
Kingdom raised and crowned her as their
princess when she came of age in the
film this justifies Peach's
determination to protect her people
however Mario raises an important
question is Peach from his world
unfortunately the question isn't
answered but it opens a lot of
opportunities to explore Peach's
backstory in a spin-off or sequel
perhaps Peach's Origins lie in
sarasaland the home of Peach's
counterpart Princess Daisy Peach being
from New York could also be an
interesting plot twist to connect the
Mushroom Kingdom with Mario's home in
Brooklyn Keegan Michael Key's toad is a
heartwarming presence in the Super Mario
Brothers movie toad is Mario's first
encounter when he ends up in the
Mushroom Kingdom for parts of the film's
early scenes toad acts as a guide to
Mario on his way to Princess Peach
however we learn that he's not
particular really unique in the toad
culture when he and Mario are denied
access to Peach's castle by the Toad's
standing guard there however toad does
manage to join Mario and Peach's Journey
to the Jungle Kingdom he shows up after
Mario and Peach depart offering to
protect her and Peach gratefully accepts
toad mainly rides in the back seat for
the adventure playing the role of comic
relief after Peach and the Kong Army's
assault on Bowser's floating island
fails Peach and Toad return to the
Mushroom Kingdom despite Peach insisting
that he flee with the rest of the city
toad chooses to stay and protect his
princess as best he can from that point
on Peach knows that he'll always be by
her side
Donkey Kong's entrance in the Super
Mario Brothers movie is one of the more
energetic moments in the film as a
Coliseum full of Kong's cheer on King
cranky Kong's beloved Son however
there's a clear history between Donkey
Kong's Showmanship in front of a crowd
and cranky Kong's acceptance of him as
DK begins to flex his packs Cranky Kong
is visibly embarrassed furthermore
Donkey Kong takes moments during his
fight with Mario to ask his father if
he's watching him when Mario ends up
defeating Donkey Kong in combat the
embarrassment the gorilla suffers
exposes just how desperately he seeks
his father's approval this leads to a
rivalry between the two characters for
much of the rest of the film by the time
Donkey Kong and Mario end up swallowed
by a mare after the disaster on Rainbow
Road a clear parallel is drawn between
their desperation to make their fathers
proud fortunately they both achieve that
by the end of the movie when Donkey Kong
saves his father he's encouraged to show
off a little and Mario's defeat of
Bowser finally proves his courage and
determination to his dad
Jack Black's performance as Bowser might
be the best part of the Super Mario
Brothers movie
do you yield
I do not the monster first appears as a
menacing Tyrant hell-bent on destroying
the Mushroom Kingdom but halfway through
the movie It's revealed that Bowser's
ultimate purpose isn't Conquest it's
love even his own Army is off put by the
idea that Bowser's main ambition is to
marry Princess Peach despite the fact
that she hates him well this leads to
some humorous sequences like Bowser
practicing a serenade for peach and then
putting on a mock Proposal with kamek
dressed as Peach it also drives Bowser's
Furious hatred of Mario Bowser sees the
hero as his primary romantic rival when
Peach ends up ambushing Bowser and his
army at the altar Bowser angrily summons
a bonsai Bill to destroy the Mushroom
Kingdom though Mario successfully
deflects the giant bullet he
inadvertently sends it careening through
a warp pipe back into Brooklyn everyone
is sucked through the portal in the
resulting blast and Bowser almost
defeats the Plucky plumber on his home
turf nevertheless Bowser is no match for
Mario and Luigi's teamwork after
defeating the fire breathing Turtle
Peach forces him to eat a blue mushroom
shrinking him down to a miniature size
toad then traps the once threatening
Baddie in a bottle in a mid-credit scene
we discover Bowser is being kept in a
cage in the Mushroom Kingdom with only
his piano to keep him company this means
Bowser will be nearby for any future
sequels
Brooklyn originated as the birthplace of
Mario and Luigi in an unlikely title the
educational game Mario's Time Machine
the brother's home was reinforced by
official comic books Nintendo Power
Magazine and the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show the New York borough has
never made an official appearance in the
video games but it plays a big role in
the opening of the Super Mario Brothers
movie depicting Mario and Luigi's
struggling Plumbing business and family
life the final scenes of the Super Mario
Brothers movie takes the brothers
conflict with Bowser back through the
green pipe and into Brooklyn it's a
moment where Mario and Luigi get a
chance to prove themselves not just to
Peach Donkey Kong and the rest but to
those who doubted them at home like
their parents and Foreman spike a sequel
to the Super Mario Brothers movie could
delve into the implications of this
Crossing of worlds in the earlier scenes
of the movie Brooklyn was in Mayhem
after an underground sewage leak this
causes a flood in the city's streets and
encourages Mario and Luigi to enter the
sewers and discover the green warp pipe
if anything it'd be great to get a
better look at the city which is riddled
with Easter eggs alluding to Nintendo's
history as well as various entries in
the Mario franchise
audiences spend quite a bit of time in
the jungle Kingdom as Peach Mario and
Toad Venture there to recruit the Kong
Army to defend the Mushroom Kingdom
against Bowser's incoming forces the
jungle Kingdom in the Super Mario
Brothers movie isn't what gamers are
used to from the Donkey Kong Country
games this jungle Kingdom for example
has roads fit for high octane kart
racing but plenty of iconic Donkey Kong
Country characters make cameos in the
movie cranky Kongs overseeing The Arena
Battle plus we see Diddy Kong Dixie Kong
Chunky Kong and even Funky Kong so a
full-fledged Donkey Kong Country film
isn't hard to imagine in fact rumors of
Illumination giving Seth Rogen's Donkey
Kong character his own spin-off have
been circulating since 2021. the only
thing left is for the jungle Kingdom to
be thrown into disarray by the arrival
of King K rule
in the post-credits scene viewers are
whisked away to the sewers of Brooklyn
the resting spot of an artifact Left
Behind from the mushroom Kingdom's
crossover a lone white egg with green
spots Super Mario Brothers fans know
who's about to hatch from that egg Yoshi
one of Mario's most famous allies
Mario's dinosaur pal first appeared in
these Super Nintendo titles Super Mario
World though the characters design dates
back to the release of the original
Super Mario Brothers in 1985. Yoshi
later spawned a spin-off franchise with
Yoshi's Island we don't get to see that
particular Yoshi in the Super Mario
Brothers movie but before the film
finally cuts to Black the egg begins to
crack and we hear his iconic
high-pitched call
Chris Pratt told CBR that the
post-credits scene gets him quote very
very excited about the prospect of doing
another movie as Mario man that guy must
really love dinosaurs
[Music]
thank you